JACKIE: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW" OUTRAGES BUILDING
OVER BIDEN SWAPPING BRITTNEY
GRINER FOR VIKTOR BOUT
ESPECIALLY OVER NBC NEWS FOR A
CORRECTION FOR THE REPORTING
ABOUT IT.
NBC FIRST REPORTED THAT THE
KREMLIN GAVE THE WHITE HOUSE THE
CHOICE OF EITHER BRITTNEY GRINER
OR PAUL WHELAN WHO IS IN
RUSSIA'S CUSTODY FOR YEARS LATER
THE ARTICLE WAS EDITED TO READ
THE CHOICE WAS BRITTNEY GRINER
OR NO ONE.
THE WHITE HOUSE RESPONDED TO NBC
CHANGING ITS STORY THIS MORNING
ON "FOX NEWS SUNDAY".
>> AND UNEQUIVOCALLY SAY THERE
WAS NEVER AN OPTION BETWEEN PAUL
WHEELING OR BRITTNEY GRINER?
>> YES, MA'AM I CAN THERE WAS
NEVER A CHOICE POSED BY THE
RUSSIANS IT WAS ONLY BRITTNEY
GRINER FOR VICTOR BOOP.
BELIEVE ME WE DID WE WERE MAKING
EFFORTS TO TRY TO GET BOTH OF
THEM OUT.
THERE WAS JUST NO WAY TO GET
THERE.
>> I AM GLAD SHE IS HOME, SHE'S
AMERICAN EVEN THOUGH I DISAGREE
WITH HER PERSONAL THOUGHTS AND
APPROACH, I'M GLAD SHE'S HOME
BUT WHAT IS ON WITH NBC.
DID NBC GET THAT WRONG OR THAT
RIGHT.
THIS COMES ON THE HEELS OF THE
POPPA LUCY STORY WHERE THEY GO
OUT AND RELEASE THIS INFORMATION
REVELATIONS ABOUT PAUL PELOSI
ONLY TO GET THEIR ARM TWISTED,
TAKE THIS REPORTER OFF THE AIR.
ARE YOU TELLING ME THEY GOT ALL
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH IT NBC AND IT
REALLY DOES MAKE YOU WONDER DID
THEY GET IT RIGHT OR DID THEY
GET IT WRONG.
WHO'S THE PERSON THAT TOLD THEM
THIS, HOW DID THEY RUN WITH THE
STORY IN NBC, THIS IS TWO AND A
VERY SHORT PROXIMITY OF TIME.
JACKIE: SPEAKING OF THE COVERAGE
ON MSNBC YESTERDAY HERE'S A
GEORGETOWN PROFESSOR
CHARACTERIZING THE WAY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PAUL WHEELING AND
THE WAY HE IS BEING LEFT BEHIND.
>> BRITTNEY GRINER IS IN LGBTQ
BLACK WOMAN WHO IS ALSO A
CELEBRITY.
SO TO POLITICIZE ISSUER BRIGADE
AND RACE, GENDER, YOU ARE
BRINGING IN SEXUAL PARKINSON'S
AND ALL THESE THINGS.
THESE ARE DOG WHISTLES.
AN IDEA THAT A MARINE WAS LEFT
BEHIND IS DANGEROUS AND CAN
SPARK A LOT OF PUSHBACK FROM
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T VERY
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT THE
ACTUAL TRUTH.
IT IT'S INTENTIONAL
DISINFORMATION.
JACKIE: SHE SAYING SOMEBODY LEFT
BEHIND IS MISINFORMATION, IT IS
DANGEROUS TO SAY THAT.
TOMI: IT'S DANGEROUS TO TELL THE
TRUTH, FOR HER MAYBE IT
CERTAINLY IS.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THE
CLIP THE MENTAL GYMNASTICS THAT
IT TOOK FOR HER TO GET THAT OUT
WAS ASTONISHING.
THAT WAS AN OLYMPIC SPORT ON ITS
OWN RIGHT THERE SAYING WE SHOULD
NOT POLITICIZE THIS.
THIS WOMAN IS IN LGBTQ BLACK
CELEBRITY.
DON'T POLITICIZE IT BUT WE
NEEDED TO BRING YOUR HOME BUT
DON'T POLITICIZE IT AND YES THE
MARINE WAS LEFT BEHIND BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE SHOULDN'T
POLITICIZE A FACT BECAUSE IT
MIGHT MISLEAD PEOPLE.
WHAT IS GOING ON.
GIANNO: THAT'S NOT EVEN A REASON
WHY IF IT WAS A WHITE NBA PLAYER
IT WOULD BE THE SAME.
YOU HAVE A VETERAN WHO SERVED
OUR COUNTRY HONORABLY WHO IS
BEHIND ENEMY LINES THAT SHOULD
BE BROUGHT HOME.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE
OR GENDER WHATSOEVER AND THEN I
THINK ABOUT JOHN KIRBY CLIP.
I LIKE HIM PERSONALLY BUT I
DON'T BELIEVE HIM HERE.
WE'VE SEEN MULTIPLE TIMES OF THE
BITE IN ADMINISTRATION OF JOE
BIDEN HIMSELF HAS LIED TO HER
FACE IS PRE-HE SAID I'M NOT
WOULD LEAVE ANY AMERICANS BEHIND
IN AFGHANISTAN, THAT WAS A LIE
IN MORE TALES OF LIES AND YOU
SAID ABOUT NBC I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON THEY PROBABLY
GOT THE STORY TRULY RIGHT, THEY
MADE A DECISION THAT WAS BASED
ON WHAT THE VOTING BASE WOULD
WANT.
THEY WANTED BRITTNEY GRINER BACK
THERE.
HE SAID HE RECEIVED A LOT OF
PRESSURE FROM BLACK WOMEN TO
MAKE THIS DECISION.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT
SUPPORTED HIM AND THAT'S A BIG
PART OF THE REASON HE'S IN
OFFICE RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S THE SET OF FACTS IN THAT
SITUATION.
.JACKIE: THE NEW YORK POST SAID
GETTING BRITTNEY GRINER BACK WAS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT AT
WHAT COST, THIS IS A BAD TRADE A
BAD DEAL THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE THE BRITTNEY
GRINER INCIDENT HAPPENED TO MAKE
A TRADE FOR PAUL WHELAN AND THE
MERCHANT OF DEATH AND THEY
DECLINED.
MIKE POMPEO TALKED ABOUT THIS.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS
VERY CLEAR WE WEREN'T GOING TO
TRADE BAD GUYS FOR CELEBRITIES
BECAUSE IT CREATES THE WRONG
INCENTIVE FOR THE BAD GUY IN HIS
POCKET FOR THEM AMERICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY AND NOT GOOD
FOR PEOPLE TRAVELED ACROSS THE
WORLD.
JASON: THAT BIDEN LOOKS WEAK AS
A RESULT OF MAKING THIS TRADE.
JASON: IT DOES PUT A LOT MORE
PEOPLE AT RISK.
WHEN YOU'RE WILLING TO HAVE
THESE TYPES OF DEALS ONE FOR ONE
PERSON FOR PERSON I HEARD ONE OF
THE SENIOR PEOPLE AT THE DRUG
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WHICH
APPREHENDED THE MERCHANT OF
DEATH AND BROUGHT HIM INTO
CUSTODY INTO JUSTICE AND HE SAID
IS IT IT IRONIC THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TALKS ABOUT GUN
CONTROL AND GETTING GUNS OFF OF
OUR STREETS AND THEN THEY'RE
WILLING TO PUT SOMEBODY BACK
ONTO THE BATTLEFIELD MUCH LIKE
WHAT OBAMA DID WITH THESE PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF GUANTANAMO BAY
PUTTING THEM BACK ON THE STREETS
SO MORE GUNS MORE AMMUNITION.
JACKIE: HE'S A WAR CRIMINAL HE
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY DEATHS,
A LOT OF CHAOS.
>> HE ACTUALLY IS NOW JOINING
THE FIGHT IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S BEEN REPORTED, HE'S GOING
RIGHT BACK ON THE BATTLEFIELD
AND HE HAS TO DO SOMETHING TO
THINK PUTIN FOR RELEASING HIM.
NOT ONLY THAT PUTIN IS REALLY
WEAK, UKRAINE IS A FIGHT THEY
DID NOT THINK THEY WOULD HAVE ON
THEIR HANDS.
NOW YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO COULD
BE A LIEUTENANT IN YOUR WAR
AGAINST GOOD PEOPLE TO REALLY
PUSH FORWARD YOUR PLANS.
IT IS INSANE.
TOMI: I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
DISCUSSION IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
AGAIN I LIKE YOUR POINT IS GUN
CONTROL, SAFETY GETTING WEAPONS
OFF THE STREETS AND WE PUT A
WEAPON BACK ON THE STREET IN
HUMAN FORM.
THEY DO SOME MORE OF THE MENTAL
GYMNASTICS AND SAY LISTEN